we only have a reported 14 episodes left
of Game of Thrones that's two years
worth of sifting through every scene of
every trailer scrolling through the cast
Instagram feeds and begging george RR
martin to finish winds of winter Thrones
mega fan site Watchers on the wall has
unearthed some casting calls for season
seven so we're totally going to try to
guess who they're trying to cast be
warned there are major spoilers ahead
warning you go on then warn me first up
a priest in his 60s the show is seeking
a white actor using an RP accent with a
face full of character for this role
he's a widely respected holy man with
high moral authority since the Wildfire
explosion took the lives of many
including the high Sparrow this holy man
could be the next to come to power
within King's Landing another
possibility this is a priest or maybe
even a maester an old town since for
sure to spend more time with Sam well
tarts a general in the age range of 40
to 55 they're looking for a white actor
with the British RP accent played the
senior military officer here's a couple
guesses on this one he could be Circe's
military commander because we know
she'll be facing serious threats from
multiple fronts if not maybe this
general could be leading the Knights of
the Vale who will most definitely have
an increased presence in season 7 after
saving the Starks at the Battle of the
bastards next up a young lord in his
late twenties the producers are looking
for a white actor with an RP accent2
betrayed his tall and handsome character
could this be a young Rhaegar Targaryen
during a flashback sequence I know
Rhaegar didn't see his late 20s but the
show is known to add a few years please
be Rhaegar which brings me to this cast
mr. a warrior between the age of 35 and
45 he's described as a tough-looking
bruiser with the attack skills of a pit
bull the roll calls for a white actor
with a non posh English accent and will
have considerable amount of dialogue
let's hope this is a young Robert
Baratheon although he would be much
younger at the infamous battle of the
Trident could this be Barristan Selmy
who fought alongside ray gars army we
know salmi was wounded at the battle and
later pardoned by breath
who made him Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard a gate guard in his 20s the
character is described as confident and
straight talking he's a northerner that
needs to have wit and charisma the
biggest question I have here which gate
is he guarding is it the wall or is it
Winterfell maybe just some other
northern castle this could be where the
Brotherhood without banners is camping
out we know the Hound is headed up north
with thoreau Samir and beric Dondarrion
a city guard in his 30s the description
says he will catch a suspicious looking
person on his nightly Patrol he has a
British RP accent similar to the other
castings in season 7 again the accent
gives it away it's probably a guard in
King's Landing and maybe even head of
the city watch who could he come across
on his nightly Patrol my hope is it's
aria with one focus crossing Cersei
Lannister off her list immersion in his
40s HBO's open to his race and
appearance but looking for a character
actor for this role he'll make an
appearance at an enduring a busy evening
but will play a noncombatant role this
in might be the inn at the crossroads
and it sounds like there may be some
colorful characters and drama on this
busy eating next lovely lady with no age
range she's described as an attractive
and confident prostitute shamefully the
part requires nudity but she will also
have a good speaking part your guess is
as good as mine we all know there's no
shortage of nudity in the show and this
could be anywhere maybe it's a lady for
Yara we do know she likes the ladies and
finally a lieutenant in his 20s
producers are preferring a man of Middle
Eastern descent to play this atletic and
disciplined warrior this sounds like a
Dothraki warrior to me he could play a
part in Daenerys Targaryen trusted inner
circle after she gave Daario naharis the
coldest shoulder in Westeros although
we're still holding out hope to see him
come to danny side before all is said
and done now you have a tiny bit of
background into the new characters that
will be seeing on screen in season 7 all
we could do now is wait and judging by
amazia Williams we're in for quite the
show
you